it was another day of incredible
volatility on Wall Street
like yesterday swings of hundreds of
points were common unlike yesterday
there was much more movement up than
down the Dow finished ahead 567 points
after taking a nosedive at the start of
the day the S&P 500 was up 46 Nasdaq
regained 148 alright let's find out what
this was all about Deirdre Bolton of Fox
News Network Fox Business Network joins
us from New York
good evening Deirdre good evening
Shannon volatility is back you gave
those closing levels but during the day
the Dow swung 1,200 points if you can
believe that it actually changed
direction 29 times definite whiplash of
fur traders treasurer secretary Steve
Newton spoke earlier saying there is a
larger economic picture to consider we
are very focused on the long term
economic growth and we believe that the
policies that we've enacted including
tax reform are very positive for a long
term economic growth the US economy has
such strong underpinnings that some
strategists say that's what started the
selling investors saw a 17-year low for
unemployment rising wage growth and many
thought it would force the Fed to raise
rates higher or quicker or even both
making borrowing of all kinds more
expensive analysts also point out that
the selling in the market has been
exacerbated by program trading computer
driven trades that kick in automatically
when markets hit certain levels what
we've seen is a clearly a sell-off
that's been driven to a large extent by
algorithms and computer trading we get
these reversals and when we get them
from the major trend they're sharp steep
quick and always painful but I think at
the moment they should be dude it should
be viewed just as technical because
nothing fundamental has really changed
economic indicators such as the US trade
deficit are more likely to catch a
professional investors eye today we saw
that the US trade deficit grew to its
widest in nine years which means the US
is buying more goods
selling if that trend continues it could
hurt American manufacturing the Trump
administration is committed to
addressing trade issues next up another
round of meetings on NAFTA in March lots
of economic indicators to watch
including the possibility of a shutdown
in DC which I know you are closely
watching Shannon we are Deirdre thank
you very much